canadians had waited 36 years to see
their men's football team reach the
world cup finals and expectations were
high in toronto
the players had failed to book their
ticket to qatar with defeat in costa
rica on friday but any nerves about
another slip-up were calmed early on
when kyle larrin slotted in the opener
[Applause]
canada were two up before half-time when
taejon buchanan scrambled in the second
and the party could get going when two
late goals wrapped up a convincing win
junior hoilett stabbed home the third
before an own goal rounded off a
four-nil victory
big celebrations at the final whistle
for the team and their english coach
john herdman only one of the canadian
squad had been born when their country
last reached the world cup in 1986.
i think once we see that world cup draw
and we kind of see who we're going up
against that'll really put things into
perspective when you realize okay you
know what you know in november i could
be going up against harry kane for
example or or someone like that so it's
stuff like that i think once those kind
of moments come it'll really really help
put everything in perspective at the
moment we're still kind of just in
dreamland so many disappointments
through the
through the through the years and uh
this is the new canada new brotherhood
new family
new everything you know
and for the fans who've waited so long
to see their team play in the finals a
moment to save her and time to plan
their trip
[Applause]
to make it to qatar now and see the
resurgence i
and now here it is the whole the whole
building smells like sulfur because
fireworks are going off everywhere
canada were ranked 94th in the world
when coach herdman took charge of the
team four years ago
and now they'll be mixing it with the
best on world football's biggest stage
lauren smith al jazeera